nella a tutti i ragazzi e benvenute
questo nuovo video sono pochi j
oggi è più se qui iniziamo su domenica
no oggi e domani che quindi siamo su
happy meals non faceva ridere
ok benissimo ragazzi direi di iniziare
così a caso facciamo un livello preso a
mi dice non ho neanche letto il titolo
non me ne frega niente ma il contesto
ok ragazzi che cosa che cosa diavolo o
aperto così cosa cosa sto giocando bene
allora ha seguito il mio consiglio non
aprite mai livelli senza leggere il
titolo che non sapete cos'è sta roba è
una corsa coi bacoli mi sembra si conta
se vai e ti fai cosi grande il plug in
ok perfetto quando si dei vorrei
bellissimo il nome prison escape the
prison escape devo scappare dai prigioni
bayern di vice cosi edy reja dovete
sapere che è di e ricercato perché mi ha
rubato la nutella quindi è ricercato in
tutti i paesi del mondo ai cosiddetti
oggi è ovviamente la scosa è sta roba
getting the teng vai così da ragazzi ma
cos'è cos'è sta roba eh va beh ragazzi
siamo stiamo fuggendo nella maniera più
epica possibile vai idevice di libertà
grande o perché è un essere umano
incastrato nel bene va bene così allora
lo sguardo di oggi provo a farlo subito
è il primo ad andarsene deve essere per
forza l'altro è di perché è un falso
lo sapete che gli è di senza casco sono
falsi perfetto poi se non lo shock
madonna io l'ho preso dritto nel naso va
bene così il padre di york vai così
ragazzi l'ultimo senza guardare lo prete
o no non l'ho preso [ __ ] non l'ho
preso non lo paga
l'ultimo impossibile grande under
pressure anche questo pone di no quel
padre di you ok ragazze lo posso fare
[Applauso]
che cazzo è successo ok raga al primo
tentativo non conta ragazzi ce l'hanno
fa mai così al così mi avvio ce l'ho
fatta impossibile rainbow ok ragan
rainbow grop swing ma questo l'ho già
fatto mi sarà risolta
il manubrio non serve ok va bene ragazzi
siamo partiti col manubrio non me lo
posso portare purtroppo mio dio che
acrobata che accetta raga solo è di solo
lui a nola porca [ __ ] maledetta the
vincolo stesso senza testa c'è ho vinto
spezzate chissenefrega smash iamm cos'è
sta roba iad vaiani userà una morsa di
wrestling sta roba da vaie puoi vedere
chi sei
va bene raga non ha senso sto livello ma
non importa target p cos'è target pit
stop di sam
io mi chiamo eddy ok non è proprio così
che ha forse comprendere l'ananas dietro
via come cazzo fatto cioè ma io ogni
tanto menetto queste cose cioè riesco a
fare delle cose ogni tanto riesco a fare
delle cose piquet non me ne rendo
neanche conto ma ben bostrom per fa vj
perfetto ragazzi boltro per fa vj ce la
posso fare
certo vaibhavi fai una cosa pica dove
vedere una casa epica e prendere che
magari ad occhi chiusi e non preso
davvero ho preso chieti mario che mi ha
tappato la vittoria fantastica togliti
dalle cozze ok l'ho ripreso lei a tutti
su cat mario tutti i socket mario è il
grande albero abbiamo ucciso chieti
marino va beh questa cosa non è normale
devo riuscire a vincere
greg di ex cos'è press the right gay e
grandi ex ok devo prendere o che ci ho
fatto l'ho presa e l'ho presa e cosa ti
sei
mi sono ucciso da solo come un pezzo di
idiotas hanno ucciso da solo come un
idiota ragazze la posso fare
ce l'ho fatta the dinner slow motion
questo devo farlo assolutamente stimoli
della birra certo è di compiacere
prenditela in faccia la len senso visto
livello ragazzi kill or be killed questo
devo fare assolutamente raga sono con
nonno ciacco delle spade di occupa
stardock l'ho preso eh no sono sono
morto fantastico si è grande non ti
appendere sul mio naso idiota
devo riuscire allora ce la posso fare la
caccia posso fare bastardo no ok lucia
andato a vuoto perfetto la denuncia no
no no no no no no no e capo papa per
haga allora casa è quella buona sicuro
mai così no cazzo è inciampato perché
culo
no fermi a parma ritardo set grande
perché vi si deve attaccare sul didietro
con l'ascia cos'è un vizio per
grandissimo questo paio lo stimo a
prescindere con lonmin già ma lo batto
ho vinto io chi chiede di arrivare
ancora c'è ancora quello sì il padre mio
bene ragazzi la situazione bruttissima
ok è perfetto questo è morto già stiamo
facendo
ne mancano due fermi fermi in fase ii
york ok sono ho vinto io brutto stronzo
non mi fa nulla un machete nel nel petto
tagli tela nonno tagli però
nonno zac azzoli fa una pippa against
all goals cos'è sta roba che devo
provare a farlo non so che cos'è se non
lo sciacca al contrario ti prendono o no
ti prendo non ti lascerò andare
va bene però va bene andiamo tutti
insieme chi se ne frega
cioè io sto tenendo lo stornello nonno
già che non si sta tenendo me è la figc
ingloba tutti quanti fantastico altro
per fare un altro un altro vostro
perfori j
ciao fogli questo livello non ci sono un
altro ma c'è anche una sfida strafaci le
13 per i video io rido come un dannato
continua così grazie mille
devo far boltro challenger fa vigeva il
fico nico il tuo nome è fantastico da
ragazzi devo riuscire a farcela
ho beccato fuori james ball cosa fa vj
small fa vj bene a dornach in area una
palla col mio nome
allora io lancia adesso della giunta
raffica un importate vanno è così vai
cos'è e cosa succede perché ce la fa
[ __ ] come ho fatto a morire
c'è una palla con scritto fa vj a sono
morto fantastico giant ball radio arriva
la palla gigante
perché se una palla che ho scritto fa
vigente maledizione ma i fan culo la
palla gigante non riesco a lanciarti
invece sì no no no
ok non entrata è talmente enorme che non
entra bene va bene così grande
la ragazza è un po impossibile sta cosa
ma ci devo riuscire se grande ce l'ho
fatta ok la sfida sarà facile sarebbe
questa la boe ma sono con è di chiaro
che ci riesca panino swing grandissima
baia di maya di se sei un grande e fa
vive modestamente 9 grazie mille allora
dovete sapere che nonno ciak ha un
passato da est e da freestyle albini
impossibile che non riesco a farse cose
mai no no no
cosa sta facendo il grandissimo 9
contrari bene senza testa non farle
sheikh cos'è cos'è è un harley sheikh no
devo prendere il pallone forse se c'è
grande devo fare il collo sì ma devo
prendere il pallone che senza questo
nome jack non capirlo the league of the
boy love death and you wanted sa cosa
vuol dire
i ragazzi non ci livello
[Musica]
tutti
raga io non ho mai visto niente di
simile cioè non ha spesso il party giura
che questo è fantastico
vabbè allora l'ho fatto anch'io la allen
sheikh ma non mi aspettavo lo facesse
anche parla di gli occhi sei un box slam
dunk millionaire cos'è vado con consip
ma non contestano o mio dio
se faccio canestro se faccio canestro
no ma l'eletto non ho già colmi che
avevo fatto un colpo di penna e scrive
al menu che fai vedere che non sei un
completi yacht almeno un canestro almeno
uno ma stiamo scherzando
maledizione madera che io direi di
concludere qui perché veramente è
successo di tutto
domani si sarà comunque lo speciale
100mila iscritti quindi ragazzi
preparatevi sei comunque vi dove è
piaciuto lasciato un commento mi piace
anche la pagina di facebook e come non i
video trovate nella descrizione
selezione per iscritti iscrivetevi né ci
rivediamo nel prossimo video bene
ragazzi
[Musica]